Hey Youtubers, It's Charlie.  This is gonna be my Walking Dead episode 13 video
probably one of the best Carol/Daryl
episode in a long time
I mean Carol and Daryl, always some of my
favorite characters but
this episode they just had so many great
moments, it was so funny for both scary and
funny reasons
just a quick reminder there's a new round of the giveaway now all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video
there's only three episodes left so I might
do something a little bit different for
the finale
I'm probably going to do a bigger giveaway for that I mean it's big freakin deal. So just careful
for spoilers from the episode as we get into the top five moments starting with
number five Rick, Carol, in Daryl are
planning the takeover
I love how Carol buried so many bullets in that walker
she's like "well i'm supposed to be
practicing, I shouldn't come back with a full
clip"
she's so on point. Rick always seems  like the leader, but Carol really seems like the
one that's doing all the planning
and if it wasn't clear, they haven't told
the rest to the group about their plan
the rest at the survivors
is just the three of them. As the episode
got on, you can kind of tell that they were
started to change their mind
it seems like it's going in that
direction but we stop a couple more
episodes so we'll see if things go
downhill
which they probably will.  It would be the
Walking Dead at things and go to shit by
the end of the season
On to Number 4 - Sasha is slowly going
crazy
Lots of great Sasha montages especially
when she was using those family pictures
for target practice
she just she can't stand life in this
community
she thinks it's all a big fiction she
still experiencing the trauma losing
Tyrese
you could argue that Daryl's going through the same thing, but he lost his brother and
dealt with it during season four so
he just had more time to process. And she
actually introed a big easter egg straight from
the comics
so in Alexandria safe zone the clock
towers really notable place
in the comics its andrea that ends up
using it so
I guess you could argue that sasha is
going to be the Andrea inside the
Alexandria safe zone
or at lease get all the big Andrea action
moments. it seemed like early on in season
five when they're doing with the hunters
that she was headed in that direction
so this is just a little more
confirmation. I know there's always
questions about like who's gonna be Andrea from the comic so
now it kinda looks like we can point to
Sasha.  The interesting thing is that in the
comics to
Andrea gets tied up with Douglas's son
Spencer so they are sticking pretty
close to the comics, I mean
relatively close Douglas's son in the
comics just was like trying to push up
on Andrea and she wasn't having any of
it
so just open up the tab for the clock
tower with the rifle in it
and those two characters Spencer in Sasha -
they will be important later
moving at number three Rick in Jesse
kind of start a little bit of a thing
it's kinda hard to tell where she's
coming from she seems really friendly
she's not openly hitting on him. I think
she likes a lot of things about him and
wants to get to know a lot better
and Rick like the idea of her. she
represents the kind of life that I would
like to have
after this is all over after the apocalypse is over.  So I think both of them are just
attracted to each other
because of what they represent.  they are
two really good looking people so
there's that going on
and it's only implied but Jesse's has
been is a little short with her. they're
gonna they're gonna develop that will
learn a little bit more about him but he
is the town doctor
which is actually kinda problem. you get
a sense that there's going to be a
conflict between him and Rick
at some point especially with this shit
this developing between him and Jesse
but if you the doctor and he dies like
if Rick ends up killing him
of if something bad is happening to him, they'll be down a skill physician which is
really bad
to be fair they have gotten on, the
survivors have gone on without a doctor
so, they'll probably be okay.   The rest the
people in the community not so much
they'll probably flip their shit. the
weird thing about the walking dead
is there's not a whole lot of sex on it
not as much as you think given
all the violence in the gore and the fact it's
on cable. I mean think about it real hard
if they were the apocalypse and you're
just trying to survive, you'd probably have
sex with the first woman you came across
just to relieve some tension. But like we said when Rick
lost his mind whenever you
thought you lost Carl and Judith
he has been so preoccupied so far that
hasn't been the first thing on his mind
but now they're in the same zone things
are calming down his mind is starting to
wander to her cash and prizes.
who among us could not say we would not
do the same thing. You could totally make all the Shane jokes you want
like he's totally putting the moves on
some other dudes wife.
he is kind of a Shane, but Shane was a lot
more willing to sacrifice members the
group
that's the big difference between Rick and Shane. the other relatively similar
people
the Rick really is a good person deep
down inside.  It's just when you push him over
the edge
tried to rape his son, that he bites a chunk out of your neck in goes crazy
But I think we're all in agreement that what's
going on between the three of them
Rick,  Jesse, and Pete, who's Jesse's husband,
is gonna do something somethings gonna
happen to push
Rick over the edge. don't be surprised that
the use that
climax that pushes into the finale. the
big WTF finale
there's some comic book moments that we
can tie to that, but but I'll explain to
my top five moments with the special
spoiler warning just in case you don't
know but the comics
be at number two though -  Daryl bonds
with Aaron over Buttons
as much as carol was my favorite thing
in this episode, Daryl was like my
second favorite
for like non-WTF reasons just because
it's so fun watching an outdoor cat
slowly become an indoor cat, if you want
to tie it back to the Claimers again
Claimed!  I felt like using Buttons the horse
was it was a very effective emotional
tool
you can call Scott Gimple and the
walking dead writers manipulative but
it totally worked. i think as an audience
like you feel so wounded
just because darryl admires this for so
much and then you watch it just get torn
apart by Walkers
you're just so sad.  Why don't you come in,  have some spaghetti, cry on our shoulders
and look you're something make you feel
better here's a bike that you can put
back together
it really feels like the show is pushing
Aaron is one and the same people
inside the safe zone like they want us
to think that he's gonna make it
is part of the survivors regardless of
what goes down in the finale
like to be a group that will survive
into season 6i think that these
they want us to think that aaron is
worthy being a survivor
as opposed to the other crazier members
the safe zone like Deanna for instance
isn't that just something they would do before
they get ready to kill someone though
so I I guess we should all worried for
Aaron's safety but I am hoping that he
makes it into season 6 because he's a really interesting character
I don't think that anything he was doing
with Daryl, like trying to get him to go
out and be one of the recruiters
was manipulative at all I think that was
completely genuine
like he sensed that Daryl just doesn't
work so well
full-time inside the community but he
also doesn't belong
outside so he needs to be able to go in
and out as he pleases
and my number one WTF moment of course
Carol
is the scariest person inside the safe zone right now
you can A: pick all the cookies in the
world
or B: I'll let you die a horrible death
outside the safe zone and your mother
will never find out what happened to
you
in case you forgot Sam is one of Jesse's
children
one of Jesse's two children so when he said
I tell my mother everything
that was actually really positive thing
but she seems like a really good mom
Carol also
really good mom for very different
reasons I like the idea that she's a den
mother she called herself a den mother
she really is but she's the den mother of like the most dangerous
children in the world like Sasha for
instance you could think of her as
one of her cubs.
looks like she's getting ready to go off
like a nuclear bomb, and Carol, Carol's just
stone cold
all those comments, though, about the
cookies that applesauce and the
Chocolate
that's for real though people do put applesauce in cookies. my favorite
moment though during that whole scene
was when he first was like I followed
you I thought you're gonna make more
cookies
I thought that she was actually gonna
kill him at the end the episode
Didn't you just feel it was going to be like a Look at the flowers moment
like, oh, well I gotta kill him now
he saw me.  there's nothing else we can do
about it. that's why I  Love The Walking
Dead so much because
this is like a really evil moment
there's something really evil for Carol
to do
but you cheer so hard because you love
Carol so much
it the same thing with Rick's character
too like when he totally goes off the
reservation
you cheer so loud. that's
actually a really good jumping-off point
here's my big question for you guys
what is your favorite evil thing that
one of the survivors is done?
like definitely crossed the line bad
thing to do but the made you cheer really
hard?
I would say before this it was like the
end a season four when
Rick bit out the Claimers neck.  Carol's
cookies now though is my number one
definitely number one
it's gonna be hard to top this. Rick
killing Pete might be a good one
but I still feel like Carol's cookies is
going to go down as like one of the
season five moments
mark my words whenever they get the
Comicon, they do like their Walking Dead
panel
the prolly have a cookie moment just
like they had a Carl pudding moment last
year
Do you hear that AMC marketing? just make a
whole buncha cookies
that is your new marketing strategy for
comic-con this summer.  Just to explain
comic book stuff is just around the
corner
like with the the W markings and
scavengers so the scavengers
are a group that are in and around the DC
area in the comics
they didn't debut to issue number
seventy five but the tie in with
Alexandria Safe Zone stories so
I'm just going to put this spoiler tag up for a second so here we go so the scavengers
want what's inside the safe zone.  they don't find out about it they don't
find where it
is until Rick kills Pete.  Like he kills Pete, it
makes his big sound and it alerts the
Scavengers
where the safe zone is and it leads to a big
conflict. right off the bat that just
sounds like something they would do
for the finale so maybe we'll see like
some crazy Rick Pete moment in episode
maybe even episode 14 but then there was
this Morgan Street
easter egg so maybe Morgan is going to
show up is that all goes down too.
I'm kinda hoping we see Jesus before
next season
we haven't met and we haven't seen
inside the safe zone but he is the safe
zone character
it's possible that like that with Negan
they're holding per season 6
so given how close we are to the finale
I'm just expecting the scavengers to be
like next big villain group
you guys can let me know if you agree
though just let me know do you think
that Negan gonna show up
as part of the scavengers group or do you think it is going to be scavengers
and then after their dealt with later in
season 6 will see Negan
so I'll post a Q&A for this tomorrow and I'll announce the giveaway winner
be sure to subscribe to get that if you haven't
already
but since I forgot to list the winner of my Game of Thrones giveaway this week in
my Game of Thrones video earlier today
I'll say Micha Houston , you win the
game of Thrones season four DVD
just be sure to message me on the back
end of my channel for contact info I'm sure
everyone has questions about what's
going on with Rick
and Jesse, what's going on with Sasha slowly
losing her mind
MIchonne putting her katana up, Daryl, totally broing out with Aaron
so many good things in this episode
there's so many things we could talk about
so while you guys wait for the Q&A, you can
click here for the game of Thrones video
I just posted the Game of Thrones season five
video
and you can click here for all my other
Walking Dead Season 5 videos
thank you so much watching, I'll see you guys
tomorrow,  now let's all do the thing